protesters rallied outside the homes of
two local leaders sunday night ccsd
board president linda cavazos and clark
county commissioner tick seegerbloom
while no one was hurt the incidents did
send shockwaves through those
neighborhoods madison kimbrough spoke to
the targets of both protests
i'm incredibly disappointed
that
people decided that they needed to bring
symbols of hate into our neighborhood
this henderson community still reeling
from sunday's tense moments as
protesters invaded ccsd board president
linda cavazos's neighborhood cavazos
husband took this video showing the
protesters outside their home some of
which even approached their front door
and now she's speaking out in person for
the first time since the incident
occurred on sunday kind of
puzzled and shocked that
the yelling that i heard at the
beginning was about mass and vaccines
name calling and some pretty scary
things actually being said the same
group of protesters invaded county
commissioner tick sagar bloom's property
knocking down lamp post and leaving
anti-vac stickers stuck to his mailbox
i've never had anyone
actually come to my house and then and
not just walk up and down but just
scream things and bull horns and
horn honking and stuff it's still a
little scary both sega bloom and cavazos
have yet to file an official complaint
with henderson police or metro but say
they are both in talks with authorities
on their rights moving forward it did
not seem like it was just a random group
of people that decided to show up in
front of people's houses